and this thing went super poorly for the
prosecutor not just according to people
who are sort of watching the trial but
according to the judge so the prosecutor
i don't know
how disbarmand is not considered here
seriously the prosecutor
twice essentially got called on the
carpet by the judge
who was very very pissed off and for
good reason
and the reason that the judge was pissed
off is in the first incident in the
first instance
the lawyer attempted to make the
argument during cross-examination
about
why he'd remain silent after his arrest
so when he was arrested he didn't talk
to the police
now it is a well-established rule i mean
literally going back centuries that
silence is not an admission of guilt
okay this goes all the way back to like
the thomas more trial
the the belief that if you are silenced
on a particular topic this means that
you are guilty
as well as the notion that if you take
the fifth amendment that this is an
implication of guilt in a courtroom
you're not allowed to even bring that up
if you're a lawyer in a courtroom
you're not allowed to
okay that's like black letter again
first year law
and the judge just reams the prosecutor
for attempting to do that i mean the
prosecutor did that he's like why did
you're really attempting to make the
argument that kyle writtenhouse not
talking to the cops means that he's
guilty
they get by the way
again quick lawyer rule guys hey if you
are ever arrested for a crime call your
lawyer and say nothing to the cops if
you're ever arrested for a crime call
your lawyer say nothing to the cops
again first year basic law
and it doesn't mean you're guilty it
means that you need to talk to your
lawyer because the police are there to
do their job and that job might involve
asking questions that implicate you in
crimes you didn't commit for example so
you always want to work with your lawyer
okay but
one thing that's not allowed to happen
is in the courtroom the opposing lawyer
isn't allowed to say because you didn't
talk to the cops this means you're
guilty
that that gets rid of the purpose of the
fifth amendment in the first place
here is uh here's the prosecutor just
getting ruined by the judge for this one
you are already you were i was
astonished
when you began your examination by
commenting on the defendant's post
arrest silence that's basic law it's
been basic law in this country for 40
years 50 years i have no idea why you
would do something like that i said i
had heard nothing in this trial to
change any of my rulings so why
testimony pardon me that was before that
get brazen with me you're an experienced
trial attorney and you're telling me
that when the judge says i'm excluding
this you just to take it upon yourself
to put it in because you think that
you've found a way around it come on
okay and then the judge says i don't
believe that you're acting in good faith
okay the second thing he's commenting on
there is that there was a piece of
evidence that was ruled out pre-trial
okay that piece of evidence has nothing
to do with the case it comes from like a
month after hal rittenhouse got out on
bail she's talking about months after
the initial incident and he was
photographed in a bar with members of
the proud boys wearing a shirt that said
free as f
that is not relevant to his state of
mind on the day that he shot people
that is not relevant okay that was
declared out of evidence by the judge
because when it comes to criminal trials
you have to weigh prejudicial
evidence against the probative value of
the evidence what that means is that for
example in a criminal trial you're
generally not allowed to bring up the
criminal history of the person who is on
trial because that does not go into the
calculation as to whether the person
committed this particular crime so if
something happens three months after an
incident in which you're wearing a shirt
that's offensive and stupid does that
have anything to do with whether you
committed the particular crime that is
in question three months earlier
the answer of course is no it does not
and the judge had already ruled that out
he'd already said i'm ruling that out
if you want to like approach me later
and ask about it you can but
it's out for now right i'll leave the
door open to myself but not to you this
prosecutor just started bringing up the
evidence that had already essentially
been ruled out in the first place and
the judge is like you can't do that i
know what you're doing here
i mean this prompted by the way the
defense to ask for a mistrial without
the ability of refiling
a mistrial of prejudice saying just end
the case right now by the way like i
wouldn't be surprised if this trial
never goes to the jury that's that's how
that's how bad this is
he says the judge just went after him
and then according to the associated
press
the defense asked for a mistrial over
what appeared to be an out-of-bounds
question asked of written house by the
chief prosecutor the judge should not
immediately rule on the request the
judge did say that the kind of activity
that the prosecutor engaged in here
essentially
was um was
bordering on
mistrial it was certainly grounds for an
appeal if written house were to be
convicted
it was it was so
it's so weak how weak was was the
prosecution's case i mean this one sums
it up how weak was the prosecution case
the prosecutor tried to link kyle
rittenhouse
and his self-defense claim
with playing call of duty i kid you not
this is a thing that happened in real
life in a courtroom
did this get does this lawyer get his
degree from a cracker jack box
like did he just mail in a bunch of box
tops and they sent him a lawyer's degree
honest to god i want to know where he
went to law school because he apparently
went to law school at like the fisher
price school of law or something here we
go
isn't it true when you would hang out
with dominic black you'd play call of
duty and other first-person shooter
video games
sometimes and those are games in which
you use weapons like ar-15s to pretty
much shoot anybody who comes at you
correct
it's a video game where two players are
playing together
i don't really understand the meaning of
your question
to be honest isn't one of the things
people do in these video games try and
kill everyone else with your guns
yeah the video game it's just a video
game it's not real life
so i i love that kyle written now has to
explain to him that video games are not
real life
well done here sir well done and
michigan university the university of
michigan law school should be
extraordinarily proud
by the way
binger ran as a democratic candidate for
the position of district attorney in
racine county and was appointed kenosha
county d.a about 18 months ago just
really well done here so the media are
now reacting to this with their usual
aplomb they're attacking the judge so
when the media aren't attacking kyle
rittenhouse for the great sin of crying
on the stand you know while he's on
trial for murder
in a clear self-defense case they're
very upset about that stephen crowder i
thought made an excellent point about
this the same people who will tell you
that it should be verboten in american
life to call people by their biological
pronouns because it might hurt their
feelings are the exact same people who
are laughing at kyle rittenhouse for
crying on the stand in a murder trial
where he's being wrongly accused of
murder
yeah these people are
not not not great people not not great
bob okay so the media have now taken a
new attack the new attack is uh that the
judge is real bad that's that's the new
attack the judge is a meanie bad meanie
who's bad
according to the new york times the
judge who's clashed with prosecutors has
been in this business for 50 years
that's according to the new york times
they have a long piece about this bruce
schrader the longest-serving circuit
judge in wisconsin
is presiding over the homicide trial of
kyle rittenhouse at times during
rittenhouse's testimony on wednesday he
took a strict line with prosecutors
clashing with them over a reference to
rittenhouse's silence in the months
before the trial and an attempt to
introduce testimony on a previous
incident the judge had ruled
inadmissible judge schroeder 75 who has
said he believes he has seen more
homicide trials than any other judge in
the state graduated from marquette law
school in 1970 worked as a prosecutor
and began serving as a circuit judge in
1983.
his longitudinality is the subject of
frequent conversation in the courtroom
in kenosha legal sentence circles judge
schroeder has a reputation for
strictness in sentencing he's known for
delivering lectures to prospective
jurors about their civic duty which in
this trial he likened to serving as an
american soldier in vietnam he
frequently complains about media bias
and the impact news coverage can have on
prospective jurors edge as judge
schrader quizzed prospective jurors he
said he has read news articles on the
written house case has asked himself
whether he was in the same courtroom
that was described in the articles he
has also acknowledged that some of the
topics raised in pre-trial hearings are
new to him until this case judge
schrader said in a hearing he'd never
heard of the proud boys
the first time i saw it or a version of
it was chef boyardee on a can of
spaghetti because the okay hand signal
is what he's talking about
in one of the judge's highest profile
cases the 2008 murder trial of mark
jensen who was accused of poisoning his
wife with antifreeze and smothering her
a conviction was overturned when
appellate courts and the state supreme
court ruled that schroeder had
improperly allowed evidence in the trial
the judge allowed the prosecution to
present a letter that julie jensen had
written and given to a neighbor as well
as a voicemail message she left for a
police officer suggesting if anything
happened her her husband would be
responsible so another case in other
words
the only case that they can find on this
judge that was overturned is because he
was too favorable to the prosecution
but apparently this means he's very bad
the judge is very so the new york times
is going after the judge you've got the
washington post
saying as kyle rittenhouse trial near's
end judge's decisions from the bench
come under scrutiny regardless of how he
is viewed judge bruce schroeder is
indisputably a man with fixed rules for
how trials in his kenosha county
courtroom will be run
some are basic some unorthodox all
reflect the experience of a jurist who
believes trials can be too easily
manipulated particularly by the
prosecution
for a jury trial if you get him you're
happy as a defense attorney said michael
ciccini a criminal defense lawyer in
kenosha wisconsin
he's appeared before schrader numerous
times including earlier this year in
that case he won an acquittal for his
client who's charged with battery
schrader's reputation has summoned
kenosha worried the 75 year old judge is
running the trial of kyle rittenhouse
the defense has already logged some wins
in schroeder's courtroom
gage grosskroots the man who survived
written house's gunfire took the witness
stand for the prosecution but
acknowledged he was pointing his gun at
ridden house when the teenager fired at
him then as the prosecution rested its
case schroeder dismissed a charge for
his alleged failure to comply with
curfew the judge said he agreed with
defense attorneys the prosecution had
not entered sufficient evidence to prove
a curfew was even in effect and then he
got sharp with the prosecutor
it seems like he's aiming to let this
man out of his courtroom scott free
we're not going to let that happen said
justin blake whose nephew jacob blake
was shot by the police last year
triggering knights of unrest by the way
if he's friendly to the defense i'm
finding it kind of hysterical that the
same people who are all in on defending
career criminals
are like yeah but we can't have a judge
who's pro who's pro-defense
that would be scary so in other words
exactly the kind of judge you would be
looking for if jacob blake was on trial
and you're an ally of jacob blake you
don't want for written house
i've noticed a slight difference in how
you're treating
prospective criminal cases i've i've
just noticed i've just noticed so
basically he's too liberal
he's too liberal is the rap against him
so now that's bad according to the
washington post
he's too liberal with defendants
i'm i'm again getting the impression
that
the media are mostly
uh are mostly interested
in a verdict that they like
according to the washington post while
generally respected schrader is not
universally loved and has been accused
of overstepping his authority
he once ordered a woman convicting of
shoplifting to inform an employee of any
retail store she entered she was under
supervision for her theft
in another case from the 1980s schrader
ordered a babysitter accused of
molesting a child to submit to an aids
chest
aids test he began requiring sex workers
who appeared before him to do the same
there's no statutory authority for him
to do that but he's been on the cutting
edge of a lot of cases wow what a
terrible man what a terrible horrible
man
clearly he will be to blame if the
prosecutor brought a crappy case and the
media went completely over its skis in
order to push a false narrative about
what was happening in kenosha and used
kyle rittenhouse as their case in point
to prove american white supremacy
for a white guy who shot a bunch of
other white guys
really
genius genius stuff
and faith in institutions has been
shaken here and it should be shaken
and and i would recommend that uh
everybody take the same
attitude when it comes to these criminal
trials as uh as we should all be taking
i think which is wait to see how the
evidence shakes out before you
immediately assume the institutions are
doing their job because of late they
have not been
we're in a battle for the culture and
for our values like and subscribe to
help keep our videos on the front line
of the fight and top of your feed